well I wanted to ask you first sort of
broadly about the vision that you put
forth in religion for atheists which is
a kind of utopian sort of look at or
restructuring or reformation of secular
society and if I maybe just sort of
broadly you could lay out some of the
ideas in the book hmm I suppose my
starting point is secular society has
not worked everything out in other words
once we reject religion if we reject
religion we still have some gaps there
are some problems with the way secular
society runs and it struck me that many
of these gaps could best be understood
through the prism of religion that we
have secularized I say in my book we've
secularized badly in the sense that
we've thrown out a lot of stuff which
was associated with religion
and which is now absent from
contemporary secular life but which we
would do well to revisit so what I do is
look systematically through three faiths
Christianity Buddhism and Judaism asking
myself always one question what here
might we use what here might inspire is
there stuff here that we've left behind
that we could in giving up the doctrinal
side of religion nevertheless have
benefitted from that's my starting point
and so I look at areas like community
education ethical structure art and
architecture
the notion of an institution which of
course the faiths are and a few other
things besides and you have some sort of
various specific proposals
you know examples from religious life
that you essentially would like to see
secularized and incorporated into the
wider society perhaps you can sort of
expound upon some of those sure well one
of the areas that I look at is education
and it strikes me that religions are in
a way giant educational machines now in
the secular world we take education
really seriously and a lot of money is
devoted to Institutes of higher
education when people are trying to
understand why we educate
answer is skills for jobs for the
economy you know to compete to be a
competitive economy that's simple enough
but there's another more noble sounding
ambition which creeps in during the more
lyrical passages of politician speeches
or graduation ceremonies and that's the
idea that education should be a source
of guidance that it should help you to
live that it should be an education of
your soul it should help you to find
meaning consolation ethical structure in
other words that's quite a religious
ambition and in my book what I do is I
trace it and I say that started in the
19th century as church attendance began
to collapse in many parts of Western
Europe people ask themselves the
question how are we going to replace
many of these good things from religion
ethics structure meaning and an
influential group of people like Matthew
Arnold and John Stuart Mill came up with
what I think remains a really intriguing
idea they said culture will replace
Scripture culture with a capital C the
plays of Shakespeare the dialogues of
Plato the novels of Jane Austen in these
texts in these works there are
possibilities for replacing a lot of the
direction and ethics and structure of
organized religions now I think it's an
intriguing idea it's also an idea that
has totally disappeared I mean if you
pitched up at a modern University say
you went to Harvard or Cambridge
University or Oxford and you said you
know the reason I'm here is that I want
to learn how to live and die I want to
know what's good and bad I want to find
meaning
I want to cope with my own mortality you
know the guys would be dialing the
number for the insane asylum it's simply
not an ambition that we're allowed to
bring to bear upon secular education and
I think the reason for that is there's
an idea that basically people are once
and once you're an adult you're kind of
together you you know you don't need
particular help the business of life is
simple you you know you need to get
married and have a family and find a job
you love and watch your parents die and
confront your own mortality and then put
yourself in a coffin but basically all
of that is easy you kind of kind of know
how to do it if you're an adult
and the only people who need help are
stupid people and they read self-help
books that's the kind of dominant
secular elite ideology so the idea of
relevance and assistance and didacticism
is absent now if you'd look at religion
religions start from a completely
different point of view their view is
we're all of us only just holding it
together we are desperate we are
vulnerable and we need assistance right
through every stage of life we need
wisdom and I don't necessarily agree
with the wisdom that is on offer through
religions I agree intermittently but I'm
fascinated by the analysis of our
fragility I think that's fascinating and
true truer than the secular model and
that leads me to think that if I was the
Emperor of all space and time I would
want to rejigger how wisdom is
transmitted down the generations I would
argue that the humanities should go back
to that 19th century vision that neo
religious vision of using culture a
scripture I think that remains a very
good idea sadly neglected so that's
where I'd be more than neglected
probably assaulted you see if you look I
certainly within the United States we
now only have a hundred thousand college
graduates here majoring in any branch of
the humanities yeah all of these
institutions like Harvard neo began to
train ministers they made that
transition the one you referred to as
expounded by Arnold and mill but you
know in major universities departments
philosophy departments are being shut
University of Albany just shut down all
their foreign language departments their
classics department in some ways didn't
that experiment fail yes I think the
fault is I mean often people say you
know the world is crass and
materialistic and the fault for this is
you know governments or horrible donors
or stupid students you know etc I have
to say with respect the fault
really lies in the humanities themselves
that they have failed to properly make a
case for their and
their vision of scholarship has
unfortunately been hijacked by a sort of
neo scientific idea that research is
what matters and that one can research
you know poetry like one can research a
scientific problem and this has put
generations of students off that the
humanities have committed with suicide
by being so cut off from the questions I
mean it's extraordinary when you think
about it there is enormous innate
interest in the question of how to live
I mean it's everywhere the idea that the
humanities departments have reached a
stage where they are so cut off from the
spontaneous curiosity of people that
they're having to shut down the problem
lies with these departments they have
simply failed to analyze the needs of
their audiences and to realize that the
material they're sitting on that culture
they are sitting on is a resource to
live by and that if they handled it like
that their departments would be opening
rather than closing this is Harold
blooms argument I don't know if you've
read his stuff on the Western Canon and
of course he faults the academic
hierarchy itself yeah what I think
you're doing yeah they brought it upon
themselves I feel sorry for them many
innocent people are you know being
sacrificed in the name of this corrupt
ideology but you know we all know you
know it there is appetite out there for
knowledge wisdom structured argument etc
and yet weirdly it goes on outside the
university the university has which
should have been the center it should
have been our monasteries it should have
been the place outside of the press of
capitalism where the best arguments
could be made and rehearsed and wisdom
taught and transferred that dream and it
really is a dream it's dream written
into the architecture of America's
colleges for the most part that dream
has been betrayed and they're paying a
financial price and while I'm sorry I
can only think they have brought it upon
themselves
well bloom bloom would argue that for
those who truly grasp as you point out
the importance of art and literature
there's no place for them anymore within
the university these people have to
exist outside you know and I think you
would sort of agree with
right yeah the problem is of course they
are disorganized and then weak and one
of the things that religion teaches us
is if you want to get something to have
power in the world you need to organize
you need to self-organize so you know
the problem of the loan you know would
be academic in their bedroom writing a
book you know it's much weaker and if
you look at how powerful religions are
it's because of their capacity to
organize themselves properly and it was
that mill and Arnold's dream was the
secular world will organize itself
around the universities it's failed to
do that and so you propose to create new
institutions well I certainly proposed a
method of rescuing our existing ones
recreating departments along you know it
seems striking to me that the
departments in higher education all
reflect academic disciplines rather than
questions of the soul so you have a
literature department which is a
completely nonsensical category really
what a literature department is as a
literature of is is a department of
human relationships that's really what
it's about so let's have the department
of human relationships less of the
department of loving and dying not the
department of anthropology or whatever
so the fact the academic discipline
comes first is part of the sickness of
the university it's part of putting the
cart before the horse I want to talk a
little bit about institutions here I
grew up in the church and as I was
telling you before your although an
atheist far kinder to the institution
than I would be you have a kind of
healthy respect for institutions there
is certainly a strain within Christian
thought that argues that with
Constantine the third century the rise
of the Christian Church did as much to
pervert and distort and to form the
radical message of the gospel as
perpetuated yeah I think I think we have
to be careful because certainly the
temper of the modern world is a
Protestant idea is that the institution
is corrupt that true religion resides in
the individual heart and that any
agglomeration of people is is corrupt
while that's no doubt true at certain
points it's also true that we have to
understand what is good
institutions which is that they're able
to agglomerate money power intelligence
and can simply have a reach that the
individual will never have so you know
I'm aware that in the secular world
there are lots of people trying to
change the world by writing books right
writing a book is the dominant method
and we found atheists writing books to
attack religion for example so you know
Dawkins Hitchens etc they want to bring
that bring religion down so what do they
do they write a book problem about
writing a book is that you're using one
instrument to deal with something which
is utterly unsuited to being attacked by
that instrument a book can't do very
much because what you're dealing with
with a religion is an institution which
is a book of course books are central to
religions but religions are also
community centers educational machines
travel agencies music halls you know
they were involved in so many different
activities and to think that a book can
sort of sharply and sarcastically just
blow this whole thing up is is to
misunderstand
what you're dealing with and as I say I
think that we're not short of very good
ideas in a secular humanist
world the problem is those ideas
generally don't have traction and they
don't have traction because they are not
part of an organized system so for
example we have lots of professors and
people writing wonderful books about
ethics how to live an ethical life lots
of stuff and yet you know go outside in
the streets of New York now is it
happening no why is it not happening
because there is not that thing that
religions are masters at which is the
union of theory and practice but that's
what's fascinating to me about religions
they are unified things so that they
have a branch of them sit some
intellects in in a corner and gets them
to write the books but then there's also
group of people who will be producing
woodcuts that can be read by anyone or
we producing you know advertising
billboards now in the modern world or
building cathedrals and and it's a kind
of because what the germans would call a
gazhams kunst ferg at the total work of
art it isn't work of art as such but it
has that element of totality it's
basically saying to people we're not
just trying to access you through your
brain through your reason
through you know your intellect we are
going to touch you at a variety of
moments in the day through a variety of
media and the secular world doesn't seem
to recognize that you know we've got
advertising and the luxury industries
and the construction industry and one
side and then we've got you know the
intellectuals in another what you have
to understand a religion it's a union of
those its its construction and its
fashion and its music and it's the
intellect all as one embedded pushing
one thing and I think this point is
often missed to what extent does the
consumer society and you talk in the
book about public relations and selling
I think you talk about them sort of
catering to people's needs yet of course
what they're actually doing is catering
to their emotional deficiencies that's
right that's right I mean there's that
always that classic distinction in Greek
philosophy between needs and desires and
that to lead a good life you have to be
able to distinguish those appetites in
you which are legitimate and linked
serious need from those which are vain
and flighty and evanescent linked to
your fugitive desires and that part of a
good life is knowing how to separate
that we've lost that sense that we need
help in doing that I mean the consumer
society is based on the idea that the
individual can make up their own choice
the individual is robust they can make
the difference between needs and desires
maybe little children can't so before
seven o'clock or something you maybe
can't show a certain kind of advert but
basically adults will be able to judge
their true needs so you can have a
massive poster in front of them saying
go to Thailand on holiday and be happy
and it won't have an effect at all
that's why we can have these posters of
course the advertising industry
recognizes that it does have an effect a
huge impact that's why advertising as a
business so but then of course the next
logical step is to ask well what are we
doing allowing a system to take place
which willingly confuses needs and
desires and therefore prevents us from
possibly accessing our best
possibilities helps us to ruin our lives
and religion is rather an interesting
that a model because really what it says
is you do need advertising all around
but you need the right kind of
advertising you need reminders of how to
live well because we're permanently
being pulled in different directions and
that's how a lot of organized religions
function that they have billboards
literally whether that billboard is a
cathedral or a temple or it could
actually be a billboard it's it's an
attempt to say you need some support the
whole of religious art is really an
attempt to support a set of ideas it's a
kind of propaganda
it's a massive tool to propagandize on
behalf of some ideas isn't it also a way
to delineate space between the sacred
and the profane yes to create an area
where you'll take time out from your
normal life in which the values that are
most close to your heart and close to
the truth can get a full chance to
express themselves this is yes this is
the sacred space this is the the
cathedral the church the temple the
mosque you withdraw from the hub of the
city and you're back with your true self
and again you see if I look at that my
first question is to say okay what are
we doing with that need now where's that
need gone now you know if this was a
serious need techni seriously by
religions for thousands of years where's
it gone
what are we doing with it and you know
people would say well there's the museum
to which well in my book I argue quite a
lot about my museums are not quite doing
their job properly so there are many
many ways in which stuff that religions
are quite aware of in terms of our inner
needs have gone unattended in the
secular world there are certainly
religious scholars who would argue that
and of course religious systems are
created by humankind and oftentimes
serve the interests not so much of
religious tenants but for those who run
them of the history of the Catholic
Church is a pretty certain one what
about those sort of critics who would
say well
religion itself or institutional
religion is to quote the theologian
Tillich inherently demonic including the
church and that oftentimes religious
institutions serve as much as an
impediment towards the capacity for
transcendence or transformation that
that the religious impulse that those
those yearnings to describe articulate
and honor the non-rational forces in
life the beauty grief
the struggle for immortality all things
that you've written about that that one
has to make a very sharp distinction
between the institutions and the
religious impulse and in many cases and
you know I covered the war in the former
Yugoslavia the religious institutions
signed on for the Crusades of ethnic
cleansing I mean they were they they
lent their they gave a kind of sacred
authority to murder look without wishing
to not in any way to underplay the
terrible role of institutions we also
have to accept that institutions can
make things possible that are not
possible when it's just the individual
and I think maybe to take the heats out
of the out of the argument it helps to
look at other areas other than religion
where many of the same things happen I
mean take the Arts and the humanities
we've been discussing it you know the
the university as a system has the same
kind of relationship between the
spontaneous inner impulse and the system
so take take the impulse to read poetry
you can read poetry on your own and you
can have some wonderful feelings private
feelings both pure feelings then you can
go to an institution you have a terrible
time they'll corrupt your understanding
of poetry they'll get involved in
departmental struggles they'll miss
appropriate funds they'll abuse students
there'll be sexual scandals and the
institution will be horribly kind of
corrupt right so you have the same kind
of dichotomy the purity of the
individual response the the perversion
and corruption and violence and greed of
the institution this
is not just a religious issue this is a
human issue now how would you look at
that my answer is neither one is the
perfect answer that you need both and
that both can go wrong you can have the
personal response that goes wrong
because it's not properly guided because
it has no traction because it just is
too it's squeezed out by the pressures
of life so actually you don't read the
poetry the or religious impulses is
squashed because you're watching
television you know or whatever so you
know let's not romanticize the
individual genius spontaneous you know
person on the hill who feels alone and
at the same time while respecting the
terribleness that can afflict all
institutions all you know businesses
churches etc they are nevertheless able
at their best moments to do
extraordinary things like build a
cathedral like Commission in Abbas mass
in B minor or Heathrow's terminal 5 or
the Airbus a380 you know in other words
when humans come together to do big
things that the result can be very
impressive but of course it can also be
destructive so I think we should stop
being obsessed with religion as an
anomaly in the corruption that afflicts
it it is no more or less prey to
corruption as an institution than any
other human institution and if you look
at the history of you know General
Motors compared to the history of the
Catholic Church now history of General
Motors only going a few you know decades
but even in those decades you will find
just as much you know venality
corruption abuse you know terrible stuff
in the history of General Motors as you
will in a in a representative chunk of
the history of the Catholic Church now
spread the history over hundreds of
years and the Catholic Church starts
looking really bad but it has been going
for hundreds of years
so let's beware of romanticizing the
individual and demonizing the
institution both have their problems
although General Motors I mean you could
say that you know it certainly embraces
the ideology of capitalism but it
doesn't
and you're right I mean you look back
certainly before the Reformation the the
Catholic Church was a totalitarian
entity which ruled as much through fear
and the threat of damnation
as anything else that there was a kind
of power especially in preliterate
Europe
which the church certainly abused these
were violent times and you know compared
to the power that existed during in you
know in in normal government at that
time I mean this was a vide the violence
ruled in families this was an age when
you know children couldn't answer to
their parents where wives didn't exist
as legal entities where the whole notion
of being a subject was not part of the
common law so I mean we're dealing with
violence right across the board and to
say you know the church in 1400 was a
bastion of intolerance you know that's
too narrow I mean look I'm an atheist I
don't you know I don't see why I should
spend my time defending the Catholic
Church but all I'm saying is let's set
it I'm also a historian and I know that
it you know it's set in its context you
know the average monastery was not
better or worse than the average
kingship so you know let's set that you
know these were violent days let me ask
you about you you quote Spinoza quote
Nietzsche and at one point in the book
you talk about how difficult which of
course is true radical intellectuals
those figures like Spinoza or Nietzsche
challenged an entire system
superstructure the assumptions of an age
both essentially cast out not only by
the institution's I mean Spinoza was
tried and denounced as a heretic and you
I wonder if those figures can ever be
comfortable in any institution you seem
to propose that it's possible well I you
know reading about Nietzsche's life he
longed for company he looked back to
ancient Greece and Rome and the
fellowship of philosophers at that time
Epicurus and his garden held a huge
earlier for him he want to be he wanted
to be part of a team but he was living
in 19th century Europe in the German
university system which you know was
even less tolerant
the university system now but it's you
know along similar grounds they didn't
recognize that they had in their midst a
top quality thinker and didn't give him
a job would he have wanted a job he was
desperate for a job he didn't want to be
an outcast at the top of a mountain you
know speaking his claims to an audience
of four he wanted to be a professor at
Basel University but he was kicked out
so you know we should beware of
interpreting a romantic view that you
know people like Nietzsche you know just
wanted to be on their own because it's
it's nice to live out of a suitcase
roaming around Europe you know you know
it's really great to be the professor of
X or Y but so long as you can say what
you want to say and that's what
Nietzsche himself dreamt of oh that's
true but I wonder whether institutions
have ever embraced thinkers who have
sort of dynamited the entire
superstructure on which social political
and economic assumptions are based I
mean Marx would be another example I I
again it gets back to that sort of
conflict between individual morality as
Niebuhr rights no institution can ever
achieve the morality of an individual
because finally institutions are always
concerned about their own perpetuation
and their own survival whereas an
individual is capable of making a choice
and sacrificing that sure I bet I think
you know there are institutions which
better or worse address the needs of the
individual and I think that's really
what interests me you know and I look at
we were talking about the humanities and
how they're not particularly addressing
the needs of their students and that's
why people don't want to study there you
know that's voting with their feet take
another institution like the world of
museums you know and you often hear it
said that nowadays churches museums are
on you churches there are new cathedrals
what's going on there what people are
saying is these are institutions where
you will find the same solemnity
reverence and enrichment for your soul
as you might have gone to religions for
now when I look at that I think well
that's kind of interesting good in
theory and then I go to the museum and I
think hmm I'm not sure this is all going
right because I think again the museum
has fallen prey to a method of
presenting its art that is to cut off
from the less
of religion religions use art in a very
simple way they use it as a way of
helping us to know how to live it's a
reminder religious art is a reminder of
how we should live an expression of
gratitude and a warning for you know all
those sorts of ways in which we
shouldn't live
that sounds really odd when compared
with you and what might be going on at
the Museum of Modern Art or whatever we
don't expect that art should have much
of an intention upon us that's the
modern curatorial system modern
curatorial system is put objects in a
white space put a minimal caption and
you know get the crowds through but
really this is not revolutionary either
the level of the individual or a society
general it exists in the world of art
and so writing my book I was struck by
the way in which religions as
institutions use art in far more
adventurous provocative ways and it's
just one example of how I see you know
lessons that can be pulled out of
religion by a non-believer and applied
to try and get some of things in the
modern world to go a little bit better
and yet the Renaissance was a reaction
to the restrictions placed upon our time
in Botticelli everyone else yes well
they think what's interesting about the
Renaissance is that it it kept true to
the didactic ambition of religious art
and indeed Roman and Greek art because
Roman Greek art is exactly like
religious art it wants to guide you and
know how to live which have been an
anaphora
under the church Roman and Greek art yes
absolutely but but that ambition that
art should be a guide to life is is
they're both in Christianity and in
pagan thought and it only disappears in
the nineteenth century under that rather
unhelpful idea that art should be for
art's sake and the idea that the artist
is a lone figure who creates works that
are ambiguous and so that the dominant
feeling you get leaving the museum is
what did that mean you know oh you know
and the the the catalogue seems like it
was translated badly from the German in
other words you you're not quite sure
what your response should be that is the
modernist elite view of art art is an
ambiguous
a medium and the more complex a work of
art the harder it will be to say what
that work of art is about but you know
religions you know ticular ticular a
Rembrandt painting like Christ crossing
the Sea of Galilee it's a piece of
propaganda it's a very simple piece of
propaganda it's a propaganda on the part
of on behalf of courage play so you're
supposed to look at that and remember
what courage is and it's very complex as
a work of art in terms of its technical
formal qualities but it's very simple at
the level of its moral and that's that's
a situation that we have a hard time
accepting in the modern world you know
how could something both be really
simple morally and yet really
complicated and so no bullet as a work
of art we expect that you know that's
not going to be the case
although secular artist did it Castle
when Guernica
Koya yeah yes I mean absolutely you see
some artists and the greatest artists I
think absolutely have that I think the
problem we at least not the artists it's
the system in which they operate you
know Mark Rothko take Mark Rothko
fascinating artists very didactic
impulses I remember going to see
Rothko's paintings at the Tate Gallery
in London as a teenager thinking wonder
what this is about wonder what it's for
I can sense a mood and it's kind of
powerful but I looked at the captioner
it just said Mark Rothko American
abstract expressionist born in died in
didn't really know what it was all about
read some books on him and really have a
sense and then years years later I read
an interview with him which the
interview said and what are you trying
to do with your art and he said I want
my art to be a place where the sadness
that is common to all of us can find a
refuge and a focus I thought wow that's
that's pretty simple you could write
that on a postcard do I do I ever see
that on the museum caption no hearing
anything but and you find that with a
lot of artists you know you know if you
had to pick a so what are you doing with
Guernica you say I'm trying to stop war
or I'm trying to get people to be nice
to each other but when you go to the
Picasso Museum is that ever stated no
because I was influenced by this and the
inverter so in other words that very
simple didactic ambition of the artist
has been drained out of it by the
curatorial system so I say that the muse
Xion world does to the visible to
visible culture what the academic world
does to written culture which is namely
drain it of its revolutionary
therapeutic didactic I submit I couldn't
agree more I would have to add that
that's what religious institutions do to
religion
interesting interesting perhaps because
I'm an atheist I don't notice that as
much I'm more impressed by the aspects
of religion which seem only to be
possible through a collective action but
you know I defer to you in this area
Mike Smith at what and it's also an
admiration that I share that what moves
you is not always so much the
institution but the ritual yes and and
rituals are designed to create sacred
space yeah they are designed to honor a
reality that goes beyond articulation
they are designed and I think is this is
also something you raised in the book
they are designed to put human beings in
their place within the cosmos yeah and
and that of course is the power there is
something brilliant about the Eucharist
in the mass I mean the way I look at it
is the ritual is a communal event it
ritual is something that a number of
people do that has an impact on the
inner self and again in the modern world
we imagine that things that happen in
your inner self come spontaneously all
with communion with with a one book or
maybe one artwork in other words there's
the group doesn't touch your soul and I
think what's fascinating about ritual is
that it's precisely an attempt to say
left to your own devices solely there
are things that you're not going to get
to so we need you know you're not going
to forgive people without Yom Kippur
you're not going to look at the moon
without the Zen Buddhist festival of
tsukimi you're not going to properly
forgive people without you know the
Jewish ritual of plunging yourself in a
mikveh or whatever that there are these
commune
or rituals which are going to have to
take place otherwise your soul will be
it will be in trouble and I'm deeply
impressed by this chiefly because
subjectively I know there's so much that
I feel and want to do that I don't do
because there is no communal structure
and when people say yeah but you know
the world you know us atheists were
brilliant at inventing things I've had
that people say that to me and I so
really great what is it and they go what
we've got birthday parties come on the
birthday party though yeah you know I
went to a 50th it was great people read
poems and you know and okay what's wrong
with of course there are secular rituals
but they tend not to be structured
properly they tend not to be
psychologically rich you know take
something like Father's Day or Mother's
Day which is a secular ritual has
obviously a religious antecedent but
it's a typically modern secular rather
stupid ritual and the reason it's stupid
is that it fails to recognize the number
one thing which is that we don't only
love our mothers or fathers we also hate
them they've led us down in all sorts of
ways that the relationship between
parent and child is conflicted and by
having a moment which only honors the
positive it actually makes a true
relationship impossible so a more
intelligent relationship but more
intentional ritual would start by saying
that relationship is conflicted so we
need the ritual to accept that and
that's what's clever about things like
well things like the Bar Mitzvah the
bomb it so if you follow a Bar Mitzvah
ceremony
it's full of acknowledging the fact that
the parents are sad that the kid is
growing up it's basically saying the kid
is murdering the father right this is a
ritual murder of the father as the next
generation grows up so beneath the
festivities and the balloons and the
party in the presence what you've got is
an intergenerational you know murder and
but it's healed and it's held together
and it's done intelligently and so that
for me is the genius of religious ritual
well it expresses and I you by they
point us out at the beginning of the
book a fundamental truth about existence
in the same way that the Greek myths
understood psychological truths it's why
Freud kept going
back to Greek myths and Shakespeare yeah
and and I think that I think I'm
certainly in complete agreement with you
that to ask the question is this
literally true is absurd from the
beginning because even biblical
literalists are selectively look you
know they're selectively literally they
they pick and choose what they want the
innumerable contradictions even within
the four Gospels you know all sorts of
issues and I think it's also it's
leaving the individual with so much
pressure to assume that we as
individuals can do all the stuff we need
to do just by ourselves you know I was
struck in reading the history of
religions is there's always in all
religions a festival of chaos a moment
when the world is turned upside down
when power relations are reversed when
sexual relations are reversed and when
in a sense all the craziness all are
perverse impulses a given room for
expression and you know whether it's
carnival or you know the Feast of Fools
or in ancient Greece the festival of
Dionysus or whatever it's a moment in
the calendar where the darkness is
allowed to come out into the light and
is regulating that's what that's what
fascinates Nietzsche in the festival of
Dionysus that it's both chaos and
structure it's a wonderful mixture and
in the modern world what do we do well
we get drunk on a Saturday night and
beat someone up or break a car or
something it's very disco ordinate it or
we have an affair and you know it's it's
it's left up to the individual it's not
cold it's not lent dignity it's not seen
as something that we all labor with so
the individual comes to their own
realization oh I've got unfaithful
impulses or oh I've got violent impulses
or oh I want to punch my boss and and
and this is seen as a private
realization against the backdrop of a
kind of sunny optimistic version vision
of man religions are much kinder to us
in saying of course this stuff's going
to be in you so we're gonna try and
structure it we're going to give it a
bit of a place in in the world well it
acknowledges the dark impulse
within humankind which of course in the
happy cheerful positive psychology world
of modernity is completely denied right
which is what I mean what I love about
all the faith's is their pessimism
you know Christian pessimism is
wonderful you know whether it's Pascal
or you know in Judaism you know the book
of Job or Buddhist texts that again
speak of the unutterable you know misery
of the grasping of human nature these
things are incredibly important to read
precisely because we live in this sunny
world where the assumption is that
children are normal creatures rather
than half crazy beasts and that all of
us are mature you know sensible people
just looking forward to the next
vacation rather than people who are you
know torn apart by serious darkness and
I love reading Christian and other
Jewish dark texts precisely because I
think oh I'm not alone here there's some
you know this has been it's also very
dignified there's you know the pros or
the poetry is beautiful the language is
beautiful so it expresses those most
private inarticulate sides of ourselves
raises them out of a darkness places
them before us and makes us feel less
lonely with some of the most
unacceptable stuff that you know resides
in the human soul well there was not a
division between art and religion when
it began that's right and and I think
there should be no longer a division
between art and what I call psychology
the psyche that that division that that
art served the needs of the soul
directly with no it didn't exist in up
the art world it was just but it was
part of ethics it was part of living
whereas we've we put it seriously in a
corner and we almost don't recognize how
much we've put it in a corner but it's
not it's not in the service of life and
yet you know both of us love Proust
Proust certainly for me gave me a
language gave me a vocabulary to
describe aspects of human reality that I
had not had before I read Proust
absolutely but you know it's not the
artists the artists are doing a fine job
it's the way they're presented I mean I
read a book a few years ago on Proust
how Proust can change your life and that
got me excommunicated from the
University I was in the feeling was with
is not a serious man if he has written a
book or hopparoo's can change your life
we don't want him here he has written a
self-help book and I was happy to go
because I thought we're not seeing eye
to eye here but it's symptomatic it's
not Proust that's the problem it's the
structure that we place around Prue's
everything all works of culture should
be how X can change your life how
Picasso can change your life how
Mondrian can change your life you know
that's a method that we've lost at our
peril but more importantly it's why they
wrote it I mean the last books and a
half of Proust is one depth charge after
another absolutely this is a man looking
for the meaning of life and defining if
you like a quasi-religious path to
redemption and and and he Proust who
knew a lot about religion is precisely
following you know and absolutely you
have some sort of specific ideas I want
to ask you about travel agents and I
mean I don't need to list them agape
restaurants but maybe you can sort of
spell some of them are well one of the
things I do in my book is provoke the
reader into thinking look what I'm
telling you here is not merely a set of
ideas I'm trying to imagine how we might
tweak the world and change the world
with the help of certain of these
concepts that we've been discussing why
do I do that I think there's a sort of
an assumption that practices in one area
and books are in another and the books
shouldn't suggest practices and because
I'm writing about religion which are all
about the union of practice and theory
it seemed exciting and interesting to
look at that so for example I'm thinking
about perspective and or all the major
faiths are interested in the feeling of
awe they realized that if you put
somebody in a space where they see how
small a human occupies it will be a
smaller human being occupies in the
vastness of space or time there will be
a curved quietening of their soul their
anxiety of their pressure to succeed and
their ego driven impulses that will
abate under the night sky in a Cathedral
in a Grand Canyon wherever it is you
will have a certain kind of feeling
still
of the ego the or the feeling of all so
I try and think okay religions are
unparalleled at doing this they do this
all the time and they're really great
where do we do this you know and people
say okay we do go to the Grand Canyon
etc but I try and imagine structuring it
a bit more the stars and astronomy is a
vital source of all problem is when you
go to a science museum they'll they'll
treat you like you're a scientist they
not they don't treat you like you're
looking for or they look treat you like
you're you know about to work for NASA
and a seriously interested in the
details of the G 102 galaxy you know 3
million light years away you're not most
of us are not we're looking to use
science or scientific material as our
religious forbearers did in other words
there's a source of all but the modern
museum doesn't allow that so I try and
imagine a space where we might go that
way we might maybe a little bit like a
planetarium or a little bit like a
science museum where the point would not
be to learn learn about science it would
be to look at scientific phenomena for
that feeling of awe and its benefits
that it can bring I even playfully
imagined that these giant screens in
Times Square that are currently
displaying the stock market data would
every now and then get a live feed from
the Hubble telescope that surrounds the
earth and so that as you're walking
along you know mired in the human
anthill you would look up and you would
see some of these galaxies and nebulae
and suddenly everything would would
change rather as it changes when you see
the towers and spires of Chartres
Cathedral across an open field in
northern France that same kind of impact
that same collision of your daily self
with something you know public so yeah
if anyone who's owning those those
screens in Times Square is watching
let's let's plug them into the Hubble
and talk a little bit about the you you
have you talked about travel you talked
about yeah communal restaurants I'm
interested in the travel business
because travel is seen by religions as
an absolutely fundamental part of a
spiritual life and that's interesting
you know because we travel a lot as well
so you think okay what did they do and
what a weed
you're talking about pilgrimages yes
pilgrimage exactly what is a pilgrimage
a pilgrimage has many things but it's
it's really an attempt to use a journey
to help your soul and we kind of have an
impulse in that you say okay well I'm
gonna go on a journey to try and do
something but we're very unstructured
about it we don't really connect our
destinations with our inner needs that
the real if you look at the circle
travel pages of newspapers that the
dilemma is always how do I find the
hotel or how do I get a cheaper rate on
something the real question of travel is
how do I match the outer world with some
evolution in the inner world that's what
religion that's how religion uses travel
so I try and imagine what a travel
agency might be like that have properly
studied religion and it's playful
suggestion but it's a real suggestion
like many of my suggestions and and
really what you would do is you would
have like you used to do in medieval
Christianity before setting out on a
pilgrimage you would visit a priest and
you would discuss the state of your soul
and a priest would guide you to a
destination you would literally have a
map or a book of destinations around
Europe and and your inner life and your
outer destination would be matched
plenty there for the modern travel agent
and you might walk because again as
religions understand often the ease of
getting there undermines the capacity of
a journey to effect a change in us there
is in difficulty a metaphor for an inner
difficulty and so by removing all outer
difficulties you undermine our
willingness to endure an inner
difficulty to change so that's and the
other problem is that people leap having
lived for 20 years in the developing
world from you know a cloistered
industrial and about to to a replication
of that yeah in a resort I mean in fact
they don't travel at all really yeah
Orwell wrote an essay about this yet
once yeah they don't travel at all and
and they're genuine rather touching
ambitions that they do you know people
want serious things from their travel
they travel in order to find themselves
in order to improve a relationship in
order to discover their children in
order to understand the world
these are
really really serious ambitions and yet
how often travel goes wrong you know
because these serious ambitions are not
taken seriously by the travel industry
well into the cruelty of marketing
absolutely where we can be so easily
dissuaded where these noble impulses can
be you know taken taken or alive yeah
you know there's going off to a Club Med
and it's gonna solve you does gonna
that's right that's right
so that's that's another area I also
look at the area of community and it
strikes me that one of the things
religions are brilliant at doing is
bringing a group of strangers together
in an extraordinary accomplished
beautiful space and through certain
basic actions basically introduced
themselves they act as hosts and just
like a host at a party will break the
ice and allow people to release their
humanity and curiosity so a religious
host does that with you know the group
of congregants we've lost that ability a
city modern city like New York or
anywhere is full of bars and restaurants
but these are corrupt visions these are
not communal spaces they are simulacra
of of communities no one really talks to
anyone or only in slightly haphazard
ways there is we lack any systematic
mechanisms for turning the stranger into
a friend which is so core to all
religions all religions have the table
at which the stranger can come and can
eat and break bread
these are wonderful traditions we spend
so much time worrying about restaurants
and the quality of the you know tomatoes
there and you know it's nonsense
compared to the real ambition of the
table and I suggest in my book you know
let's get some tables where we you know
it doesn't really matter what you're
gonna eat
the point is friendship and community
and that ancient religious originally
religious ideal of breaking bread with a
stranger you don't talk about theater in
the book classical theater and I'm
wondering especially having lived in New
York after 9/11 and the whole build-up
to the Iraq war the the one institution
that sought to remind us of the horror
of war was not in fact the church yeah
which pretty much signed on for the war
as an institution but theater and there
were numerous productions suppliant
women I mean all sorts of great stuff
that we're done and theater itself has a
kind of sacred quality and it gives it
it you know in some kind of way almost
brings back to life or the past or
ancestors it has a communal quality and
has a rich Rodgers wonderful yes I
accept all of that if I were to
criticize theater and a lot and in
relation to religion certain religious
communal rituals have elements of
theater you know a mass etc but it's not
simply what that theorists I think it
was border called the society of the
spectacle know if they son of a guide to
war it's de ba de Boer exactly what de
Bob wisely called the society of the
spectacle
he criticized modern culture for
extraordinary things happening on the
stage and all of us there like this and
he kritis
modern societies where there's
extraordinary stuff going onstage and
that has an impact on the audience and
you leave transformed and with an energy
to transform and I've been in so many
plays wonderful moving plays where the
audience is wrapped and the audience is
ready to go anywhere that the play has
taken them anywhere we are in ecstasy we
are in a state of ecstasy and we are in
the hands of those actors and then the
curtain comes down and we go and buy an
ice cream and head out for a taxi and go
home and that's it the whole thing sure
the energy that was in that theatre that
could have transformed the world it
dissipates and so you know I look back
to a more radical theatrical tradition
you know of Brecht and you know there
were others who've thought about this
that theater should not just exist in
the Playhouse that it should maybe style
in the Playhouse but that it's for you
know everyone and that tradition looked
very much to religion as an integration
of spectacle and public engagement in
and yet in times of repression and I
covered Pinochet is Chile yeah
art and theater I mean the two major
institutions that stood up to Pinochet
were actually the church theater I think
I think you're right how many think
people do walk out and are sort of a
Nesta sized but that's because of the
sort of the culture that's upon them
once everything stripped down
I mean Susan Sontag went to Sarajevo
while it was being shelled and
surrounded and dude waiting for Godot
and that has a power to speak when
whenever when all of those false
comforts are gone I think oftentimes the
inability to hear and see as you point
out is is the narcotic well I think it
comes back to this idea of how seriously
we should take works of art and there's
this assumption that even though we pay
reverence to art and aren't so important
etc we don't really want to allow it to
transform things and whenever a very
powerful work comes along just the way
in which I don't know but there's just
this you know it wouldn't want one
wouldn't want to call it a conspiracy
but it almost feels like a conspiracy to
strip it of its truly transformational
power as I said you know we all know
films or plays you've come out and you
think I want to change my life you know
this piece of work has urged upon me an
agenda that is so different from
everything around but the problem is
that by lunchtime the next day you've
kind of forgotten it and you know by the
next weekend it's gone and there's
something new at the theater and you
know and that's it
so we don't have follow-through and
again to look at religions religions are
all about circling their saying you know
there were these insights there were
these powerful insights we're gonna go
back to them because you know you knew
them on Sunday but you're forgetting
them by next Saturday so we're gonna go
back to them and modern culture it's
almost like it can't take its own
highpoints seriously enough it
undermines itself and this constant
search for the new the new is great as
you keep on good things in the new but
this this sort of them this neglect of
repetition and rehearsal seriously
undermines the capacity of any one work
of art to really affect change when you
have
you certainly do with Judaism and
Christianity systems of thought that
were written by an oppressed class to
what extent is that theology aimed for
the oppressed I I was in a refugee camp
in the war in El Salvador and they were
decorating the camp for the day of the
innocence which and I knew the story I
heard my father read in the pulpit and I
asked one of the refugees why it was
such an important holiday and they said
because on this day Jesus became a
refugee Jesus had fled with Mary and
Joseph to Egypt and
before Herod came and killed the
children and I who had heard the story
from a position of privilege in some
fundamental level had although I could
recited verbatim didn't understand it
and I'm wondering you know if you look
at the antebellum South you had two
strains of the Christian religion you
had black a black church and you had the
white slaveholding Church which used the
Bible of course to defend slavery and I
think there's a theologian James cone
has made a pretty strong argument that
in many ways he actually calls the white
church and not just the antebellum
Church but the white church he calls it
the Antichrist because and he talks a
lot about lynching as sort of our modern
cross and I just want to do you know is
we close if you could address that issue
that issue of justice that issue of
oppression and to what extent finally
religion you know or religious
theological systems in some ways may not
have been written for people like you
and then look I think there's something
immensely important in a message which
is there in all the major faiths which
is a defense of the vulnerable the weak
the child the dispossessed and more
broadly the self that exists outside of
power money and status all religions are
at their purest on the side of that in a
way on the side of the the status list
person the secular world is a winner's
Society you know we live in capitalism
capitalism rewards productivity and
economic merit and demonstrable economic
success this is an immensely punishing
ideology that leads to madness at its
most extreme because only a fraction of
the members of this planet and even the
members of the United States can ever
live up to that ideology under that
ideology a huge portion of the world
citizens and American citizens are
losers and that can't be right and where
do the losers go what what ideology
that has led half the population to be
defined as a loser this can't be the
right philosophy and what religions are
very cleverly and intelligently done is
to say no that's the wrong ideology that
what matters is not power and status and
the possession of vast castles but the
inner self the inner being the stuff
that a parent would love in a child that
outside of power relationships when we
love outside of power relationships what
we love in people is the pure person and
that that's what matters and in
different forms that's what all the
religions say love the powerless love
the child love the weak person love the
mortal self not vanity not power etc and
we need that voice desperately and what
saddens me is that it's really only the
faith's that put forward that voice
articulately it used to be put forward
by Marxism and by the left
unfortunately the left was discredited
by all sorts of economic positions and
it failed to capitalize on really what
was its richest area which was its
emotional analysis of what we need by
focusing itself as a scientific economic
cure to the ills of mankind it fatally
shot itself in the foot so we're now in
a world with as capitalism on the one
hand and faith-based organizations on
the other and what gives the faith-based
organization such strength is that
capitalism labels so many people losers
I think as the absolute ruler of the
world if ever I were I would say what we
need is a non faith-based ideology which
recognizes the dignity and humanity of
the vulnerable and the weak and the
child all right well thank you very much
thank you so much